immaginiamo di passeggiare in un bosco
in un prato lontano dalle costruzioni
dell'uomo tra la grande varietà e
complessità di forme che ci circondano
individuiamo subito dei moduli
ricorrenti delle regolarità delle
simmetrie nel continuo movimento e
mutamento qualcosa sembra conservarsi
certe strutture sembrano essere
privilegiate e così ci accorgiamo che un
fungo per esempio è uguale da qualunque
parte lo guardiamo un millepiedi è
costituito da tanti anelli che si
susseguono uno dietro l'altro tutti
uguali tutti disposti in fila indiana
una farfalla se osserviamo una farfalla
che si poggia su un ramo allora ci
appare solo metà della farfalla ma se
immaginiamo di accostarlo ad uno
specchio la farfalla ci apparirà per
intero perché avviene ciò oggetti ed
organismi viventi simmetrici hanno dei
vantaggi sono stabili compatti
intercambiabili in natura l'informazione
sulla forma e contenuta nei geni e
costruire strutture simmetriche forme
simmetriche richiede una quantità di
informazione minore piuttosto che
costruire strutture non simmetriche come
in una catena di montaggio è più facile
rapido efficiente la simmetria e quindi
semplicità ma forse anche per questo la
simmetria è sinonimo di bellezza
sin dalle origini il pensiero greco
elaborato un modello di bellezza basato
su simmetria e proporzione sua armonia
delle forme sulla giusta relazione
giusto equilibrio tra le varie parti che
compongono un insieme e anche tra
aspetti diversi di una stessa realtà le
stesse qualità che il divino demiurgo
cercava di mettere in atto
nell'opera di costruire l'universo
secondo platone addirittura il mondo
intero era costituito da poliedri
regolari i cosiddetti solidi platonici
ad ognuno dei quali veniva associato un
elemento
aria acqua terra fuoco l'universo stesso
ma la esigenza di proporzione simmetria
riguarda anche la rappresentazione del
corpo umano
nell'antichità nell'età classica lo
scultore policleto raccolte in un
trattato che amato canone o già andato
perduto una serie di norme e di regole
che dovevano servire a definire il
modello ideale di corpo umano ed egli
mise in pratica queste regole del canone
in una statua chiamata doriforo il
portatore di lancia che oggi possiamo
osservare in tante copie che sono state
poi prodotte in età romana e che
rappresenta per noi tutt'oggi l'ideale
di bellezza classica e questo ideale di
bellezza
prosegui quasi immutato nei secoli fino
a raggiungere il rinascimento tutti noi
conosciamo l'uomo vitruviano di leonardo
da vinci dove un'immagine di un corpo
umano risulta perfettamente iscritta
nelle figure di cerchio e di quadrato
tutte centrate nell'ombelico e viene
messo in risalto la proporzione le
proporzioni degli arti attraverso dei
rapporti numerici definiti la simmetria
per me è un po tutta la nostra vita il
nostro rapporto con il mondo esterno ma
l'asimmetria non è soltanto qualcosa che
percepiamo quando guardiamo la realtà
che ci circonda o che cerchiamo di
riprodurre nelle nostre rappresentazioni
artistiche
l'asimmetria non è soltanto quel
qualcosa che la cui presenza o mancanza
produce in noi quel misto di stupore di
piacere che sta alla base della
sensazione dell'armonia
l'asimmetria non è soltanto nelle leggi
dell'universo nelle forme dell'universo
ma nelle leggi dell'universo e per
questo diventa per noi fisici uno
strumento potentissimo di conoscenza il
principio di conservazione dell'energia
per esempio che uno dei pilastri della
fisica si fonda sull'invarianza delle
leggi che governano i sistemi per
traslazioni temporali
noi diciamo che un oggetto è simmetrico
una figura e simmetrica se scambiando in
modo opportuno le parti che la
compongono la figura complessiva rimane
ancora invariata quindi invarianza sotto
l'azione di trasformazioni nello spazio
così come abbiamo visto per il fungo di
prima che era uguale da qualunque lato
ci giravamo per guardarlo ma anche nel
tempo una mela che cade cade con la
stessa legge
adesso come cadeva con la stessa legge
ai tempi di newton simmetrie quindi e
leggi di conservazione capire un po
meglio questa legge di conservazione
possiamo ricordare la frase che un po
tutti abbiamo sentito tutti conosciamo
in natura nulla si crea nulla si
distrugge tutto si trasforma
ecco prendiamo per esempio un bel vaso
di cristallo acquistiamo un bel vaso di
cristallo e magari non troppo costoso e
lo pensiamo e risulta che pesa non so un
chilo bene ora lasciamolo cadere per
terra e osserviamo lo mentre si frantuma
in mille pezzi
bene se pesiamo ciascun pezzo ciascun
frammento del vaso otterremo ancora un
chilo e se non è così
significa che c'è qualcosa che non
stiamo considerando perché qualche pezzo
troppo piccole non abbiamo raccolto la
nostra bilancia non è abbastanza precisa
perché l'energia si deve conservare e
noi abbiamo una fiducia pressochè
assoluta in queste leggi di
conservazione fu in base proprio a
questa fiducia che nel 1930 venne
ipotizzato l'esistenza di una nuova
particella pur di impedire che in un
processo di conservate di un processo di
decadimento radioattivo naturale il
decadimento beta un decadimento di un
nucleo atomico il principio di
conservazione dell'energia venisse
violato
quindi il nucleo atomico era per noi
come il vaso ogni volta che andavamo a
contare i pezzi ce n'era sempre qualcuno
che mancava qualcuno che mancava
all'appello e ci doveva essere qualcosa
una particella mancante che doveva che
ci aspettavamo che fosse lì ci vollero
quasi trent'anni perché quella
particella venisse effettivamente
scoperta
stiamo parlando del neutrino neutrino
così come lo battezzò il grande fisico
italiano enrico fermi che gli diede un
nome italiano appunto neutrino saper
piccola particella neutra e questo è il
nome che noi oggi utilizziamo per
chiamare il neutrino in tutte le lingue
non solo in italiano
oggi del neutrino sappiamo tante cose
sappiamo che una particella priva di
carica elettrica neutra punto sappiamo
che ha una massa piccola piccolissima e
sappiamo che ogni istante il nostro
corpo è attraversato da decine di
migliaia di miliardi di neutrini senza
che ce ne accorgiamo quindi i neutrini
sono particelle elusive le più elusive
dell'universo e quindi per questa
proprietà è difficilissimo che
interagiscano con la materia circostante
e che quindi noi possiamo osservarli
possiamo rivelarli e proprio per questo
motivo ci sono ancora delle proprietà
fondamentali del neutrino che non
conosciamo
una di queste è un'ipotesi affascinante
e bellissima è che il neutrino possa
essere l'antiparticella di se stesso
queste ipotesi venne formulata da un
genio della fisica
ettore majorana nel 1937 proprio un anno
prima che sparisse misteriosamente nel
nulla
ettore majorana aveva scritto in un
articolo intitolato teoria simmetrica
dell'elettrone del positrone di queste
le proprietà di questo e di alcune
particelle
tre i neutrini ha anche se ancora i
tempi non erano mai stati osservati e
quindi secondo lui per questo per alcune
particelle neutre
i neutrini appunto non fosse necessario
introdurre le antiparticelle quindi una
teoria asciutta ed elegante che
prevedeva il numero possibili di ipotesi
che il neutrino è anche la sua
antiparticella beh ma come fare a capire
se è vera l'ipotesi di majorana e quindi
se è vero che il neutrino e la sua
antiparticella neutrino è uguale
all'anti neutrino ed è qui che entra in
gioco un processo dal nome
difficilissimo doppio decadimento beta
senza neutrini che sembra un po il nome
di un tuffo olimpionico per capire che
cos'è questo doppio decadimento beta
senza neutrini partiamo dal decadimento
beta normale standard quindi il
decadimento beta è un processo di
trasformazione di decadimento appunto di
un nucleo atomico che si trasforma in un
altro nucleo atomico e se all'emissione
di un elettrone e di un anti neutrino
bene questo processo noi lo conosciamo
abbastanza bene lo abbiamo studiato
tante volte avviene in natura
conosciamo molto del decadimento beta
ora in natura può accadere che questo
decadimento beta sia doppio cioè il
nucleo atomico si trasforma in un altro
nucleo tonico vengono messi due
elettroni e 2 anti neutrini quindi due
ampi neutrini
ora cosa succede se è vera l'ipotesi di
maiorano e quindi neutrino è uguale
all'anti neutrino beh allora in questo
caso neutrino antin uterino particelle e
antiparticelle materia antimateria si
troverebbero vicini durante il
decadimento e quindi quello che potrebbe
succedere
e chi si annichiliscano null altro cioè
si annullino l'altro come accade alla
materia quando si avvicina al
antimateria e quindi in questo caso
avremmo un decadimento doppio
decadimento beta il nucleo si trasforma
in un altro nucleo
si emettono i due elettroni ma nessun
neutrino anti neutrino doppio
decadimento beta senza neutrini ora
l'osservazione sperimentale di questo
decadimento potrebbe darci ci darebbe la
prova dell informazione certa che il
majorana aveva ragione cioè che era vero
che il neutrino era uguale a
l'antineutrino bene il problema è che
questo decadimento doppio decadimento
beta senza neutrini è talmente raro che
finora non siamo mai riusciti ad
osservarlo sperimentalmente quindi non
l'abbiamo trovato bene qual è allora
l'atteggiamento che noi ricercatori noi
scienziati possiamo avere nei confronti
di un processo un fenomeno così raro
talmente l'oro che la natura ci sto
tenendo nascosto non ci sta facendo
vedere
beh potrebbe essere un atteggiamento di
tipo osservativo e questo è quello che
fanno molti scienziati nel mondo cioè si
mettono nelle condizioni di maggiore
sensibilità nel possibile nella misura
in modo tale da essere pronti preparati
ad osservare il decadimento se dovesse
accadere spontaneamente come quando ci
mettiamo a guardare il cielo stellato e
aspettiamo una stella cadente bene
oppure c'è un altro approccio anche
quello che più mi ha coinvolto ed
affascinato di più nella mia esperienza
ed è quello di cui io mi occupo nella
mia attività di ricerca e cioè di
stimolare in laboratorio attraverso gli
acceleratori di particelle le stesse
transizioni nucleari che dovrebbero
avvenire nel doppio decadimento beta
senza neutrini spontanee e quindi
osservare studiare quali sono gli
aspetti in comune
questo ovviamente non è per nulla facile
per fare questo abbiamo costruito dei
laboratori dei laboratori in cui è
possibile accelerare un fascio di
particelle farle collidere su un
bersaglio è così fornire grazie
all'energia delle parti
quelle che acceleriamo fornire ai nuclei
che compongono il bersaglio l'energia
sufficiente a fargli compiere quelle
transizioni che stiamo cercando quelle
transizioni che sono molto simili al
doppio decadimento beta senza i neutrini
è come quando ci troviamo davanti a una
porta chiusa e noi vorremmo entrare
dentro aprire la porta ad entrare e
allora che cosa possiamo fare possiamo
stare li ad aspettare che qualcuno esca
spontaneamente dalla porta quindi ci
apra la porta e ci permetta di entrare
oppure possiamo provare a bussare alla
porta e quindi farci aprire ora questo
bussare alla porta della fisica nucleare
significa proprio questo fare degli
esperimenti delle reazioni nucleari
quindi utilizzare fasci di particelle
che incidono su un bersaglio e rivelare
poi i prodotti della reazione nucleare
ma questo non basta perché quello di cui
abbiamo bisogno è comprendere quello che
sta succedendo ora il nucleo atomico è
un sistema molto complesso
sappiamo che è costituito da protoni e
neutroni ma che interagiscono tra di
loro attraverso una forza di cui ancora
non conosciamo tutto e quindi abbiamo
bisogno di modellizzare di comprendere
che cosa sta accadendo nella reazione
nucleare per trarre le informazioni che
ci interessano
quindi ancora una volta la ricerca della
semplicità dell'eleganza della simmetria
per comprendere anche fenomeni complessi
come quelli della delle reazioni
nucleari
beh spesso si dice che nulla c'è di più
distante dallo slancio creativo
dell'artista del lavoro razionale
quantitativo rigoroso dello scienziato
che la bellezza di un'opera d'arte e il
valore il pregio di una teoria o di un
esperimento scientifico siano due
aspetti completamente diversi che non
possono essere confrontati ho nemmeno
descritti con gli stessi
i parametri e invece non è così
molto spesso più che complicatissime
teoria o ipotesi formulate ad hoc
e proprio la semplicità l'eleganza
l'armonia che guidano i ricercatori nel
percorso verso la comprensione della
natura che ci circonda
grazie
[Applauso]